hey jared what are you what are you
doing i'm just getting ready for the
show just uh just cleaning my carry
piece here my sig
p238
nice firearm
okay
i didn't know that you carried a 380.
right i didn't that's fine that's that's
fine for you i just
i wouldn't be caught dead without
at least a nine millimeter when i leave
the house oh wow
what
i got with my head there's just a
misunderstanding clearly i don't think
it's cute that's funny you say that
because that that's just my that's my
ankle piece for my ankle holster
i don't leave the house with anything
less than
glock 21 45
but you know i think that's just me i
think we're getting wires crossed i
think we're missing each other because
this is this is my backup
no i don't leave the house anything less
than my
military spec
set at an ar-15
a femur holster
but for you i see
that's that might be fine for you i mean
that target right you know acquisition
isn't a problem or that but you know for
me first it's me personally
i don't need the house
fully loaded bazooka okay holsters are
hard to come by i can imagine finger off
the trigger officer aimed in my general
direction but you know that's just me
that's just
personal preference
one second
[Music]
but i don't leave the house with
anything less than my a1m1 abrams style
battle tank
[Music]
oh yeah
i never leave the house with anything
less than my a10 warthog
60 caliber mother
that's okay i guess if you're not
planning on anything more than one
assailant
you're not gonna be president all right
this race is over trump will not be
president
[Applause]
but truthfully
okay i never leave the house frankly
without the keys to the nuclear coats
[Music]
that's what i know
speedy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ancient art of qatar we're still
practicing it because to uh learn about
other people's cultures is to appreciate
their cultures producing in video studio
as always with me is jared who is not
gay follow him on twitter at not kate
jarrod me at askrider i fulfill my legal
applications draw your own conclusions
are we good we are good i don't care
that much because you're sick it's true
hopefully it's a shallow grave at g
morgan jr
with us you doing well sir so i'm doing
great doing great
emphasis on the [ __ ] i don't know why
they felt the need to do that in a lot
of novels novellas it was a shallow
grave shallow grave
you're dead enough you're pressed for
time i mean
uh huge show tonight we have paul joseph
watson and dennis prager so we're going
to skip along and get to them i know
many of you were excited had some
questions for them
before we get to news about the mother
of all bombs dropped on isis in
afghanistan and we're going to talk
about north korea because they're acting
up uh vagina museum
that's a thing there was a
fundraiser for a vagina museum which is
going to be opened
you wanted it
you have it now
a vagina museum of course huffpo was all
on board with this a museum regarding
vaginas and this was trending it was
people sent it off on both sides of
course you know feminists thought that
it was a straw man to say that they
simply screamed a vagina but now they
literally want a museum that is just my
vagina um
so
there's not a whole lot to discuss here
you can sound off with your opinions but
most happy about this future
installation uh was timmy so he seems to
be pretty
that's the look of a man who knows what
he wants um
i understand this apparently there's
some kind of a penis museum that exists
i guess on poland because they have
nothing else to do there
what do you think
you know that was not a conversation
with men no
we it's not we need a penis museum it's
probably i wouldn't be surprised if it
was it was like hey guys what are you
like making like like a [ __ ] dick
museum
dude dude that's hilarious yeah exactly
oh the feminists are gonna lose their
minds
how does this help
well i guess your
understand i understand this you know
women these feminists i get it that some
of them they want a big giant vagina for
them because they they do have a complex
they have a chip on their shoulder and i
understand it at a certain point it does
have to be tough because the best at
everything in history almost always as a
man the best soldiers are men the best
doctors the best surgeons the best
scientists the best chefs
the best women apparently
[Laughter]
you
were better at being you than you
can
the best women's wrestler in texas is a
boy the best female track and field
athletes are now men you opened this
door and now you're trying to rectify it
with a big giant hoo-ha museum well good
luck with that i think the damage has
been done
uh speaking of damage the u.s did drop
the mother of all bombs in afghanistan
today we don't have a ton of information
right now just so you know um
we've been locked up in the studio
recording some some bits for you and
also pre-recording for next week so
people who are watching this in a time
capsule on youtube or on soundcloud
really you didn't
we don't know yet
sincerely stephen from the past
we get comments for people who like
listen to this two weeks from now like
why don't you talk about this because we
didn't know it wasn't a podcast auto
updated by the benefit
um so it's it's called a massive
ordinance bomb and comes in at 21 600
pounds damn
so basically the biggest bomb we have
outside of a nuke um
let's be real here they they talk about
how it was retaliatory action because i
believe a soldier
possibly possibly was killed
yeah this is this is slapping your
swanson on the table that's what's
happening right now donald trump wants
to be the not obama and i i think this
is just a a warning shot that we're not
to be messed with yeah he's basically
saying i'm not like the last guy because
she really misjudged me yeah hey what do
we got over there no no no no go bigger
yeah let's get the biggest thing we've
got i think that's what's happening here
um all i know is i want to watch that
thing when i max i know i want to sit
back and just just let it rip can we
drop it like in utah where nobody cares
anyway and it's not going to have a
radioactive cloud and just see what
happens utah is full of beautiful
country beautiful people
we have some wonderful fans in utah
we love you um so we actually actually
you said i don't think we do have
footage of the actual bomb being dropped
a lot of you know media they're kind of
speculating we do actually have footage
of what we do have a screenshot of the
location after the bomb was dropped in
case you were so looks like there's a
little bit of a change in topography oh
how to update the maps
you're going to go there and see kell
[Laughter]
i'm not against this is isis in
afghanistan i don't think you're going
to see a lot of criticism with syria i i
don't think they're i don't think assad
or isis at that point are a huge threat
it really is more of a humanitarian
effort uh with afghanistan i think
pretty much everyone is on board after 9
11. even even leftist even barack obama
was like yeah well they said why are we
going to iraq iraq didn't attack us
afghanistan did and that was kind of
their trump card and so
dropping bombs in afghanistan is
actually kind of politically popular i
think you get a pass yeah
i think you do and i don't think there's
gonna be a lot of collateral damage out
there um here's something though that
does worry me uh you know we've been
talking about for those who missed it on
monday's show
we went through the entire timeline with
uh syria with assad with the russians
who backed who how the conflict started
how the rebels how isis was created uh
when the red lines were drawn by barack
obama when he went back on the red lines
and claimed he never drew the red line
so on monday we did this pretty in depth
i think 20 plus minutes on just syria
and how it was created i'm not saying
i'm the first to do it but a lot of
people emailed us and said hey you know
that was helpful i i didn't really have
a firm grip on what's been going on
there
and this gives me a little bit of a
foundation so go and watch monday's show
those who are mug club members but we
want to do the same today
with north korea because a lot of people
uh aren't super aware of what's
happening with north korea there's a
there are rumors that they could be uh
testing some some nukes on saturday
because it's it's an anniversary of some
kind um i'm pretty i will say this i am
actually more concerned with north korea
than i am with with uh syria um and i
understand geopolitically syria is
important
and i understand the implications with
with assad and with putin i get it
uh remember that time when we used to
talk about donald trump being a secret
russian agent and those were good yeah
way back in the day but with north korea
i mean even if they can't hit the united
states and they very likely can't they
can hit south korea and they can hit all
of our troops who are in military bases
around there so and they're crazy people
you know a lot of times like well they
won't do it because they know there's
mutually assured self-destruction yeah
but this is a crazy person this is kim
jong-un he's not a sane human being
and i know you said
they kind of they they
a little bit of saber rattling when
anybody else is getting more attention
than them yeah i know it's like the
brother is like no no listen to me we
should just send dennis rodman and he'll
fix it yeah yeah exactly that is what
happens with north korea by the way kim
jong-un went to western schools why
didn't we just kill him then i don't
know we had a chance
um
so what other capabilities we don't know
japan came out and said that they do
believe um north korea is capable of
striking with sarin gas so so that's
getting pretty serious uh we don't want
to go all the way back to the korean war
in in necessarily kind of china and that
relationship but let's start with sort
of in in modern times what's been going
on with north korea 2005 2006 that's
when they first admitted that they had
nuclear weapons and they started
conducting tests so that's important
that's kind of a new era of of north
korea in nukes in 2007 and 2008 they
shut down their main reactor and they
agreed to inspections
in return for massive aid packages so
kind of like a kid who was sent to his
room but he was hungry
oh no we cool right i didn't mean it and
came back and they said okay
we're going to play nice send the
massive eight packages that was 2007
2008 2009 they decided to renege and
begin testing again
so
i had my fingers crossed um
stubby little fingers then in 2013 there
was the third nuclear test they
restarted all the facilities they fired
more rockets for those of you who missed
this by the way i should i should
preface this nearly every time these
these tests have been conducted or
they've launched off rockets or missiles
um the the reprimanding that has taken
place has been the u.n
wagging their finger and putting in
sanctions and then doing nothing
yep all the way back to 2005. nothing
zero uh i think you saw on team america
they're talking ah han sprex you're
breaking my ball so that that's pretty
much if you're going well how do they
keep doing these tests for people who
are younger who don't know well it's
because all that happened was i'm going
to count to three i'm going to put you
in timeout and they just kick their dad
in the balls and then every time i'm
serious next time i'm serious
okay for the snook
oh you're going to be in very big
trouble little kimmy um so i think you
said 2013 yep uh third nuclear test refi
uh 2014. so they entered in talks uh to
stall they fail new sanctions are
imposed in
2014. and then in 2016 2017 uh now this
is where we have more tests uh they
claim to be able to mount nukes to
missiles and uh they claim that they
will not they will attack the us
mainland so i get that it's it's kind of
funny because a lot of people think well
they don't have the capabilities we
really here's here's the truth we don't
know
anything about their capabilities we do
know i think it was 2005 they had a one
kiloton
bomb and in 2010 it was 10 kilotons so
you can see that there is a progression
there which i find troubling and i don't
think they can hit the us mainland a lot
of experts intel experts are saying
that's the case but it is kind of
guesswork because north korea is a
security state and we don't have any
intel there on the ground
but we do know at the very least they
could mess some stuff up for south
koreans who are a great ally um and uh i
i this would be something i'd keep my
eye on this would be something i would
keep my eye on because
them acting up could create a lot of
instability but you were talking about
how you don't think they will gerald
because it's very different with china
this go around yeah they've kind of run
out of friends in that neighborhood they
don't have a big backer anymore so i
think the the politics are a little bit
different right now i do think that
you're right they are crazy they can
mess up south korea a lot and that's the
only reason we haven't done anything
right now by the way it's because south
korea can get nuked very quickly
um but i don't i don't think they're
gonna do it i just think they're getting
some attention that's their game
they're doing but there does need to be
a certain point
right like we're talking about with red
lines and that point needs to occur
where we go okay they're an actual
threat and we just we can't know so i
think that there's going to be a lot of
guesswork probably in this presidency
more than any in the last 20 years i
think north korea is going to come to a
head and i think everyone's kind of been
laughing about it for a while uh
but but we'll see what the capabilities
are and if they're even remotely
threatening
i think it's going to look like the ice
castle well if there's any place in the
world that we should be going into it's
definitely north korea the problem is
who do you snipe
there's no sanity at any level in the
government you pretty much have to take
out all of them yeah i guess you just
have to take out the entire lineage but
they do it half the time with their own
relatives um so
i will say this i it's one thing to
watch it for me it's something that
worries me more about about syria or
russia because again russia is out for
their own self-interest i think putin is
a totalitarian who kills political
dissidence i do believe that's happened
but i think by and large they're not
looking to conquer the west i do think
north korea would love to they just
don't have the capabilities too but
don't take your eye off them because
they are very very crafty and very
resourceful
south korea you will now feel my wrath
as i jiu jitsu your own utilities
against you
firms away
can you hear me now
you're about to incur roaming charges
[Music]
not a big wardrobe budget there
that one came together toward
the last
minute
but listen
you get if you give them an inch south
korea they will take a mile
exploding phones belong in a novelty
shop
not with sprint maybe with sprint
maybe with sprinting next hell uh okay
we have to move on we don't have a ton
of time here uh islamic apologists did
you see this gerald jared i i did yes
there's a group uh in australia uh what
is the name it's women's of
something australia anyways influential
political group uh islamic group and
this has been making the rounds been
very viral of these muslim women it's
it's a group for four muslim for muslim
women by muslim women there's no net
there's no lifetime for muslim women
please god no
um you think it's bad another one it's
always an affair and an abusive husband
it starts off with the abuse of husband
with ninjas you've got to add the [ __ ]
a lot of times it's full of [ __ ] shows
you know that's yeah in lifetime it's
true it's true they are over represented
that really bothers me um
well let's go to a they were explaining
away
how
it is okay to beat your wife in islam
these are muslim women let's watch i
want to make this point very clear that
he is vomiting
not obliged here or not encouraged but
he's permitted
to hit her
no that's it
permitted that's exactly what i found
for a minute not advocated you say
tomato i say beat the [ __ ] out of you so
and here's the thing a lot of people
will just say well let me just say well
you know these are just these are not
extremists no these are not extremists
this is mainstream islam and even if you
pin any muslim down uh they will try to
point to an example of their holiest
prophet terrorism be upon him muhammad
that he didn't really beat his
six-year-old wife that badly here's the
exact verse now i'll read it for you he
said was it the darkness of your shadow
that i saw in front of me i said yes he
struck me this is aisha writing he
struck me on the chest which caused me
pain and then said do you think that
allah and his apostle would deal
unjustly with you
so
by the way for those who are saying well
that's one verse taken out of context
what i would like you to do is is take
your quran or hadith and open it up to
what is commonly referred to as a page
any page pick a page and you can read
five pages in any direction
um
first off before i move on gerald
because you you've taught a lot about
this yeah is this an extremist group
that's that's outside of we know
muhammad did this but how common has it
been historically in islam to beat your
wives it's very common and i think if
you if you have the time watch before
and after that clip that we showed
because before they're like you can you
can sternly warn her and if she doesn't
come around you can deny her sex
essentially you won't sleep with her
deny her
that may not have been the best option
for them but then hitting her is lasting
he's permitted but he's not prescribed
and then right after that she goes and
it's such a beautiful thing and i'm like
are you serious she said that right
after that right after that it's such a
why didn't we include that in this case
it's hilarious i was like are you that's
that's real life this happens yeah and
where are the feminists
again for example out there and i know
people just said you sound hypocritical
because uh let's worry about our own
country but this is being uploaded to
facebook yeah as a as
a justification for islam it's a
justification to beat their wives so i'm
not saying you have to go in and start
an organization in the middle in every
middle eastern country i'm not saying
feminists you have to start up an
organization in iran or start up an
organization in palestine what i'm
saying is when they even come into your
own backyard and post a video
encouraging and teaching people how men
can beat their wives according to their
religion
where's brianna woo where's lacey green
where where's naomi wolf were any
feminists on this and i don't mean it
should just be a peep or a comment this
is some if you want to censor the
internet
for cr how is this allowed to stay up on
facebook we say beyonce dances like a
[ __ ] and she does
it gets removed but ah if you only beat
your wife lightly zuckerberg's on board
he didn't even say lightly it just said
beat your wife you can beat her you
tried two things third strike she's out
sorry what galactical wormhole did i
fall into where this is okay on facebook
and and nobody is talking about it on
the left emma watson was busy for
commenting yes emma watson
she could not be reached for comment i i
it really is remarkable and again i
always say this don't look to the
muslims in your college class who goes
with you to the bar because they're
basically a secularized muslim look
wherever muslims
congregate and create power look at any
muslim country throughout history look
at anywhere muslims either become a
majority or wherever muslims even have a
small portion of that country where they
become a majority as you see in the uk
as you see in france as you see in
sweden this is always what happens
not sometimes not kinda even when you
point back to the great advances made
under the ottoman empire even though
when you point back and you try and
claim that they created the modern
numerical system which is debatable
considering the influence from the
greeks even when you go back and try and
claim all of these great things that was
invented under muslim society guess what
their wives were still getting the hell
beaten out of them it was okay
so it's always sucked
islam is the enemy of western
civilization islam not all muslims but
muhammad and islam i think that's fair
watch this get removed and that thing
stay up watch youtube demonetize this
video and that one's going to have
tampax pearl faster than you can say
jihad
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is a weird sponsor it's a very
coveted demographic for tampax
they feel that they've been using pads
for far too long oh that's true try the
pearl it'll change your point of view
speaking of things that really this is
just it's not necessarily news we have
to get to paul just watch and then
dennis prager bothers me a lot can we
stop with the female the female hero the
female badasses yes can we stop with
that i i do we all when is this
unwritten agreement where you all have
to act like oh yeah yeah i'm impressed
oh yeah alias oh oh yeah i buy that
ronda rousey would beat 230 pound man oh
yeah oh yeah like like if we say
something we're sexist or if we act as
though we don't want to see these films
it was atomic blonde now the latest one
was charlize theron you can see here
that the trailer number two was released
where she
beats every single man in an unrealistic
fashion and everyone tries to act like
oh yeah see women can be badass too i
just look at this that's just
nowhere in the natural realm does this
even occur oh a front kick doesn't send
her back
with female that superheroes i get it
wonder woman okay it's supernatural you
can do you can do anything you want with
it but just no like secret agents the
whole kind of female james bond the
female john wick thing it is
unbelievable and that's why you have to
suspend the laws of all physics to make
it seem like they could win a fight
is it me or like set a garden hose
around her shoulder there what does she
do i feel like there's a meeting that i
wasn't there for where we're all
supposed to act as though in the right
circumstance women can be as tough as
men you have to go to the right japanese
guy hidden in the mountains of some
crazy mountain and that guy will teach
you the tricks that's right kick ass
everywhere you go what you have to do is
you have to run and stand in front of
her and count to three before you
actually do anything and let her hit you
are you serious what is he waiting i
don't you know i know i'm gonna get
flack for this because courtney got a
bunch of flack when she wrote this
article um okay let me show you a couple
let me show you two clips here that i
watched and here's the truth is i know
that films are supposed to suspend
reality but not when the filmmakers go
out and say this shows that women can be
badass this shows that women can be just
as tough as guys that's the cell that's
the feminist cell i want to show you two
clips where i i couldn't stop myself
from laughing so hard it just removed me
from it that's why i can't watch this
film let's see these two instances and
i'll give you a play-by-play
okay front kick that's the second time
she sends a guy flying with a front kick
that doesn't happen
okay and here this is my favorite look
she she she takes out trained killers by
hitting them
with an empty high heel
when i first watched i said oh it must
be a heel with like a blade like austin
powers no she's just whacking him with a
shoe
like an old lady who's being mugged in
central park okay uh the first one where
she's hitting with a heel just just to
prove to you
how unrealistic this is and i don't
believe the the the symbolism of the
female empowerment the high heel the
feminine combined with the badassery
is not lost on me uh i allowed nakajura
to hit me as hard as humanly possible
with his high heel watch okay exact same
scenario but we removed the head rest
here so that you could so he might even
be able to generate more force
jared holding the stiletto the exact
same way clearly stronger than a woman
life and death struggle would this stop
me go
go
i love the noisy made what are you what
are you related to
for those who can't see i'm not saying
that it's pleasant
but you would still kill him yeah it's
unpleasant don't get me wrong it's
unpleasant but it's like your little
sister grabbing your hair like
you know stop it and then you get her to
marry an islamist who beats her because
justice is a dish best served cult um
then there's the front kick where she
front kicks and it sends a guy
flying
that doesn't happen i'll show you
exactly why again i noticed twice we see
charlize theron defying the laws of
physics because she's a strong woman two
times she front kicks a guy and he goes
flying now i want to clarify it's
possible to send someone flying with a
push kick or stomp kick but to do that
you need to be going forward to gain
leverage so we are going to allow jarrod
again stronger than a woman surprising i
know he beat courtney in the arm
wrestling match we are going to allow
him the opportunity to front kick me to
the chest as hard as humanly possible as
many times as possible and i will stand
i won't take a staggered stance to see
if he can kick me back okay so uh jared
knock your dirt face me okay lift one
leg up for a second now edward the sound
guy come back here go back to back to
make sure he's straight
okay
now you can put your leg down
okay
uh this should be about my distance okay
edward your services are no longer
required
now jared i want you to you could you
can wind up you kick me in my arms as
hard as possible
not
it can't be done
damn it
by the way
don't think that he kicked me in the
balls that's how houdini died and uh one
more just because
one more
bonus round the ultimate female
empowerment shot can i as many female
heroes have done in the past hold a man
against a wall against his will with
merely my stiletto
it didn't take long
again the laws of physics a front kick
will kick you back and if you're holding
someone again they have a wall
they have all the leverage in the world
what are we doing charlie's angels uh
dark knight uh i think scarlett
johansson how often do we see that
stupid stiletto shot i'm sitting there
like he hasn't he's not he has a wall
but it looks so good on tv it just it
just it just it just honors the goal
oh my gosh it's so silly it looks good
stephen and heels you know a part of me
thinks that we deserve whatever north
korea has in store for us we'll be right
back we have paul joseph watson then
dennis breaker
[Music]
if even one more of you join my club in
support of freedom i will be forced to
flex my military might and launch a
full-blown missile attack
here's a taste of what's to come mug
club members
[Music]
keep the change you filthy american
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys one percent you heard me talk
about this uh last week one percent in
the wake of all the youtube censorship
uh
you know paul just wasn't talking about
it's pretty scary they're demonetizing
everything that's even remotely
controversial it's just one more
percentage point of people who watch the
content support the content for free uh
join the mug club at lottery with
creditor dot com mug club and if you're
a student as many of you are at 69 it
ends up being less than six dollars uh a
month to get the entire network the
daily show not gay jared show as well as
this lovely
hand-etched mug hand-etched here in the
united states um we can't tell you how
much we appreciate you've seen a few
commercials on this show really i think
only about three or four sponsors we're
able to be really limited with it and
we're able to continue putting in
sketches that are funny and only picking
sponsors that we really want to work
with because our our sponsor is you uh
the people who joined the mug club
joined up with crtv you really have
made this
an unbelievable place for people to work
there's you know 11 employees right now
and growing and
the biggest irony is we get to continue
putting out content for free on youtube
fighting back against uh leftism
wherever it may lie
because of mug club members so it's a
lot of credit.com mug club uh 99
annually 69 for students military or
veteran and honestly if you are any kind
of student at all
we're going to let you slip under the
radar
[Music]
all right i think there's a leak
i got water on my forehead yeah no joke
is that or i'm bleeding from my scalp uh
i don't know what just happened that
totally interfered with my street
fighter dance i have no idea i have no
clue where this came from uh our next
guest you know 11 people were very
excited that we have him and dennis
prager on the same show what a lineup uh
you know him
on the youtubes uh prison planet and you
know he's gonna be hosting actually alex
jones show uh i believe the show there
in austin i don't know if he'll be in
austin next week but as for now he's
still across the pond paul joseph watson
how are you sir
good stephen thanks for having me back
it's been a while thank you now
sometimes you look like you just woke up
from a nap or is that just your thing
i think it's the red eyes i've just got
permanently bloodshot eyes from staring
at a computer for 16 hours a day but
yeah i get that comment a lot you and my
former uber driver he said he had
macular degeneration while he was
driving me to the airport
it's fine out here and then but it's
just like right here which is what i
need to drive and so i still five-star
him
because i felt guilty
i've made a similar sacrifice if i look
up at a blue sky now it's just floating
black bits in my eye it's just it's not
going well it is degenerating in a hurry
well that's because you're not supposed
to stare at the sun paul um
so okay you you've caught some flack and
you've caught some support this week we
were talking about this uh a lot has
developed even today
with donald trump you were obviously um
a supporter there obviously against
hillary clinton i think everyone was and
you were not thrilled tell me if i
missed characterizing with with his uh
his his missile strikes in in syria
well you know stephen i've been speaking
about that issue for about what is it
six years now since the syrian civil war
started i couldn't suddenly just come
out and say oh yeah i've i've campaigned
against this for six years and said that
it would be a terrible idea hillary
wanted to do it obama nearly did it
there was the big revolt within the
military we don't want to be al-qaeda's
air force so i can't suddenly just turn
turn around and do a complete 180 and
say now that trump's doing it it's
perfectly fine and i support it which is
a lot of people weren't in that position
right after this big fallout over the
past two weeks because their whole
shtick is they support donald trump and
that's their only pivot point they can't
pivot to any other issue they can't
really talk about any of the subject
it's we love trump we support trump we
trust everything he says so they're in a
bind so if he does something that
hillary clinton literally called for
hours before it happened in the case of
the airstrike on syria they can't get
out of that that bind because their
entire short-lived internet career over
the past what 18 months since you know
the trump phenomenon arose to prominence
is based on supporting trump and nothing
else yeah so i understand why they they
can't even question him at this point
but you know we don't live in north
korea it's okay to question dear leader
he can still support him and have
questions about some of his recent
policies which are causing concern right
i i think it's totally valid i i agree
with you even even if i don't
necessarily or some people in this room
don't necessarily agree with your
position on syria um
they agree with the position of
consistency and i will say you know that
happened
how dare he
you know that happened with the
alt-right right it was it was a witch
hunt for anyone who didn't support
donald trump i think a lot of people
thought you might be in that camp um
i i know that you weren't but some
people might have falsely thought that
because the alt-right was i remember
even at one point i was like well you
know what i actually think ted cruz is
probably more conservative
let's attack let's flood the the
dislikes let's flood the comment section
and uh and that was good money right for
a while you and i know this if you 100
supported trump for a while that was
really good money having a nuanced view
or a balanced or consistent view was not
good i think i see that changing though
now because just the anti-establishment
uh angle isn't enough so have you have
you felt that have you felt some other
people kind of on your your team was
like yeah i can't support this if i was
against it uh for six years
but
aside from people who have talked about
syria for six years michael savage ann
coulter stefan molyneux you know rush
limbaugh to a certain extent all these
people people have got huge audiences
they immediately came out and said this
is a ridiculous idea what are we doing
trump literally tweeted about 25 times
since 2012 2013 an intervention in syria
helping the rebels the jihadist rebels
that hillary clinton and obama helped to
arm and fund this is going to be a bad
idea let's not do this let's not get
involved so for him to then to turn
around and do exactly that let's not
forget that this air base that they
supposedly bombed and you know some
reports say oh we wiped out 20 of their
air force some reports said half of the
missiles didn't even hit this air base
was about an hour away from a christian
town in northern hammer that is being
besieged by isis every single day and
that air base was used to defend this
town against isis so whether it's being
taken out or not if it's not you know we
had the reports it was up and running a
couple of days later other reports said
it had been taken out those christians
in that town were put directly at risk
that normally wouldn't fly with quote
conservative trump supporters many of
whom are pro-life many of whom are
christians themselves but again that
wasn't factored into the equation there
was no investigation a top mit professor
has come out today and said the evidence
clearly suggests to him
this ordinance this munition was not
dropped from the air that it was
exploded on the ground you had the white
helmets who were aligned with the
jihadist rebels going in there some of
them without gloves without masks
touching these victims so there are
numerous questions there hasn't been a
major investigation there was an
investigation of guter back in 2013 the
un said that the rebels did it right and
it later came out seymour hirsch said
that they mishandled chemical weapons
and that's what set off that explosion
so it's not tin foil hattery conspiracy
theory land to suggest that it might be
a false flag given that all the
motivation for pulling it off lies with
the rebels that's not what would be
my question there that who who created
the false flag
is that the trump administration at that
point uh i mean if we know that you know
putin obviously backs assad i've heard
this out there i'm not saying that
you're inherently wrong i don't know
that i that i buy it yet um i think that
donald trump regardless is responding
emotionally and i don't think that's a
good thing i think he's responding
emotionally and i think it's hard to not
be emotional but if it's a false flag
who staged it what's what's the answer
there well firstly when when you say
it's a false flag the media reacts like
how dare you question this look at the
dead children yeah that's horrible we're
not saying that people didn't die we're
not saying that this is horrible we're
saying let's look into it who has the
motive
robert perry came out big iran contra
journalist you know award-winning
journalist he's got sources they're just
as reliable as these unnamed sources
that we're suddenly told to trust right
whereas before when trump was a russian
agent they were all lying but now we
have to trust them but his sources
there's not a whole lot of russian agent
talk anymore after this that at least
disappeared and that is a relief to an
extent because i was sick of talking
about it every single day it was boring
as hell but yeah i think i think i think
i think i think i think he came out and
said that his source said that this
there was a drone with these chemical
weapons on that came from a
saudi israeli base in jordan and that
they were responsible but who knows
there hasn't been an investigation what
we do know is that del ponte the un
investigator came out in 2013 and said
the guter chemical weapons attack was
because the saudis gave chemical weapons
to the rebels they mishandled them there
was an explosion then they used it to
try and sell this intervention exactly
as they did on this occasion and you
know that area where the chemical weapon
attack happened it wasn't a militarily
significant area like there were no huge
concentrations of of rebels in that
particular
particular area so it just doesn't make
sense yeah you know let me ask you
tillerson came out march 31st said assad
is part of syria's future isis was on
the run they're restricted to these few
remaining areas why on earth would he
turn the entire world against him once
again by staging this
for no benefit there wasn't even an
offensive going on in that area
at the time it just makes no sense okay
so moving because we don't have we don't
have a definitive answer to that right
you're asking questions but let me ask
you this question um as you've talked
about being consistent here
do you find it grating that a lot of
people who are in this always support
trump cam no matter what no matter what
no matter what everything good that
happens is donald trump and everything
bad that happens is jared kushner or
ivanka have you noticed that's kind of
the new thing it's like well this really
i know donald didn't want to do it but
this is kushner it's his fault and
that's one of those things to me that's
just like you know kind of like
trumpcare they're like oh it's paul
ryancare well listen obama didn't draft
the bill by himself we called it
obamacare you know the healthcare bill
ultimately rests at the feet of the
president have you noticed those kind of
mental gymnastics as someone who's
consistent and does it does it get your
goat
i've noticed it among some people but a
lot of them are going further now and
just outright supporting kushner and
ivanka as well
just if trump says it's true if trump
says it's good it's good so they've gone
beyond that level now in fact there's a
guy called bill mitchell who i've been
having a back and forth with on twitter
i debated him he debated stefan molyneux
as well
and trump will tweet a picture of him
having a meeting with business leaders
in the oval office and bill mitchell's
response to that is oh my god another
massive win and it's like it's a picture
of trump having a meeting with some
people
i i i know a massive win i don't know
everything is a massive win yeah it's
just complete it's ridiculous i don't
even know that the trump election is
necessarily a massive win as we see now
it was a win but we went in with some
trepidation and there are a lot of
things that he i think he's had a rough
week to be honest i don't think he's had
a very good week um i think he's had a
rough couple of weeks so uh let me ask
you about this first and then we'll go
back to the uh
syria deal how do you feel about this
just obviously happened today uh the the
big the mother of all bombs dropped in
afghanistan you know since that's on
isis do you have a different view on
that
definitely unless it comes out that it
killed like 200 civilians but we we also
had the incident where they uh bombed i
think it was the kurds who were fighting
isis in a different area of syria that
killed 18 troops who were supposedly on
our side right but you know with in this
instance i'm glad that trump is dropping
bombs on isis
uh and not dropping leaflets like obama
did you remember that report a few years
ago
they had the trucks with the isis allies
driving the oil transporting the oil and
like two hours before they would drop a
leaflet saying excuse me this bomb
that's coming in two hours might cause
environmental damage and of course they
all got out of the area and no one died
so i'm glad that he's dropping bombs and
not leaking actually you're miss
reporter they dropped jehovah's
witnesses who were passing out leaflets
okay i gave uncle
um you know a lot of people don't know
that though we dropped leaflets in uh
japan before dropping the a-bomb to let
them know they're saying leaflets for
that's one thing that people don't know
like there was no warning there was
plenty of warning so leaflets usually
usually uh are used to precede uh the
big attack which never occurred with
barack obama okay going back to syria
then um
assad is bad isis is bad they're bad
people so
disregarding kind of what's more stable
for the middle east what should the
united states do because you don't sound
like a complete non-interventionist um
do you just think that syria is not
somewhere we should be involved in be be
gone out of there like uh acme coyote
leaving a trail of puff of smoke
i think we should help them fight isis
and get the hell out of there i mean
look at what happened in libya i mean i
did a poll
on twitter which is you know half haters
half supporters at this point with trump
saying if you support the intervention
in libya did you also support obama's
intervention and toppling of gaddafi it
was like 25 said they supported both so
there's still a complete inconsistency
there but no i think we should support
isis uh support um assad
gonna be taken out of context
this man says we should support isis
sean spice has said that they plan to
destabilize syria like three days in a
row but he is a [ __ ] can we agree on
that sean spicer is just uh he he is he
is barely walking upright he's dumber
than a bag of hammers that guy has to go
he is under a hell of a lot of pressure
every day but he has made several
errors in recent days yeah and not
necessarily i don't think that the whole
gassing thing was the biggest one i
think he literally said like three times
wow the goal is to destabilize syria
nobody really picked him up on it right
but no i think it's a complete disaster
the intervention in libya directly
caused the migrant crisis it fed into
syria no we should stay the hell out of
there every opportunity we get unless
it's it's a direct threat to you know
america or britain i mean that's i've
had that line
consistently my entire adult life so why
would i change it now trump is not kim
jong-un it's not a cult of personality
it's okay to question his decisions and
who he's being advised by yeah i agree
with you and uh um we had a conversation
where i was more non-interventionist and
gerald thought it was time to go in and
we even had disagreements in this room
and i think that those are healthy um
final question what about the freaky
little muppet over there in north korea
so you know he's saying that they have
capabilities uh obviously they have they
have 10 times the uh sort of nuclear or
chemical arsenal that they used to have
it's they don't have the missile we
don't know because we have no intel
there because it's a security state but
uh if they keep acting up and they keep
talking about you know taking out a lot
of people not only the united states but
at the very least they could do south
korea and some military bases um it's an
interesting question because i know
you're more in the school of rand paul
with that at what point does the united
states get involved with a spot like
north korea who's becoming more of a
thorn in the side of the free world
well as as far as i understand it he
doesn't yet have the capability to
strike the us i mean if he was literally
shooting up missiles which they can
still shoot down at this point as far as
they understand it then yeah it's a very
different situation what most people
don't take into account is if there was
an attack on a north korean nuclear
reactor or even just shooting down one
of their ballistic missiles they would
probably start something with south
korea i mean they sunk a south korean
ship what back in 2010 and killed like
50 people south korea sat back and did
nothing i think they did it in 2016 uh
it was even more recent i think but yeah
yeah but i mean
he probably will just go into south
korea and it will start a conflict that
will kill millions of people i mean
that's what most of the experts say so i
think you need to be very careful about
it the good news is that china's come
out and seems to be um you know more
accommodating of doing something about
it themselves they've turned back the i
think it was the coal that they were
taking from north korea so
but i mean it's it's a difficult
situation it's very different from syria
because you have a population where
it is almost
to make that comparison it is almost
hitler nazi germany like where in fact
is worse in some aspects
north koreans are terrible if you look
at the way they treat prisoners they
really are
awful very comparable to that thousand
people in concentration camps political
dissidence
women get pregnant the gods will
literally stamp the baby to death while
it's still inside the womb absolutely
abysmal i think there's a there's a
documentary called cam zone 14 which
explains it and you know these these
aren't biased reports these are
established people have escaped to china
they've escaped to the west they're all
telling the same story right so it's
very diff although you know assad is a
dictator and a strong man the absolute
torture and terror that's going on in
north korea
i would support
an uprising from the north korean people
but it's never going to happen because
they're completely brainwashed and
they're they're starved they spend all
the money on the military but again they
spend a lot of it on kim jong himself he
doesn't look like he's missed a meal in
a while um no it's like you could line
up you could line up every north korean
and just just from uh you could have a
mild view you'd be able to say that's
kim jong un right away because he's the
only one
um oh gosh we don't have a ton of time
we have dennis prager coming up next uh
paul joseph watson where can people best
find you or do you have any closing
thoughts i don't want to cut you off
you can find me on youtube just search
for my name or twitter prison planet
the only other thing is is the youtube
issue which we didn't get to touch upon
but that's a big deal right now it
doesn't really affect me with the d
monetization because i don't make money
off of it but it's clearly the fact that
the mainstream media is losing its
audience you know like fox news is
average viewer is 68 cnn's average
viewer is 60
59 sorry so i mean that's why they're
extremely worried about it and the right
is dominating youtube i said that on
twitter they all laughed at me then vice
came out and said no he's actually right
conservatives are dominating youtube
that's what they're concerned about
they're concerned about pewdiepie having
54 million subscribers and not being
controlled by a media conglomerate you
know he gets three four million views a
day that's almost equals bill riley
that's why they're concerned about it
that's why they're pulling out the
advertising yeah well you know i'd love
to have you back to talk about that
specifically we've had people discuss
that uh i just knew that uh you had an
interesting take on syria um but yeah i
think a lot of people aren't necessarily
aware karen strong will be on she had a
good take on that youtube's capital is
their viewers they've lost money but now
mainstream media wants access to the
capital and so the best way to do it is
to force out the people who beat them
consistently uh in online content if
that happens i think it'll cannibalize
itself so i do think long term youtube
will probably have a rebalancing of
itself but let's have you back soon if
we can if you're if you're ever
stateside too let's have you back and
and talk about the youtube thing paul
joseph watson follow him on youtube even
though they're demonetizing him and
we'll be back dennis prager oh dennis
breaker
[Music]
do not listen to steven crowder and join
muk club to fight back against youtube
censorship i've been working with
youtube for a long time and resistance
is futile and if you depend on your
american government to save you
they have to find me first
[Music]
[Music]
wish we could
[Music]
all right that was pantomime and we're
getting interpretive dance here
our next guest i'm thrilled thrilled to
have our next guest i've wanted to have
him on for a while i am a longtime
listener nationally syndicated radio
host and of course the creator the
founder of the feast of
prageruniversity.com mr dennis prager
thank you for being here sir
sir it is good to be with you and you
made one of our videos this is true i
did i made one of your videos over there
and
i believe it was about democratic
socialism and was surprised as to how
well it did because it's generally not a
super entertaining topic the democratic
socialism
but you were entertaining we make it
entertaining and we do have a huge
built-in base so it's a good combination
you do it is remarkable and i think a
lot of people out there
a lot of younger people now know who you
are i think they don't necessarily know
though that you
are almost single-handedly responsible
for really introducing
a lot of people like christine hoff
summers to the more conservative sphere
um you know prager university was it was
a big platform for her i know you've
worked with adam corolla so you've
managed to bridge
some of those divides that a lot of sort
of cable news talking heads or am radios
just just haven't and i'll tell you from
my perspective as a long time listener
i've always loved that you do like the
male female hours one that i really like
um the uh the ultimate issues hour
explain to people who don't know either
think of am radio as all uh republican
and democrat politics but you're one of
the only hosts i can think of who gets
into
listen you need to fundamentally think
about issue a b and c to know where you
line up and i think that's lost well
yeah
well that's that's really the reason or
the biggest reason for 35 years of radio
and i think i'm the longest continuous
radio show in the us right now wow and
uh it's not a boast i mean it sounds
boastful but it's not mentally but it's
okay
meant to make your point and that is if
all i did was news
i i would not uh have had this success
i i the truth is
if i had my choice i would do very
little news
and i would only do tremendous issues
see i'm as interested
in in you said the male female hour yeah
i'm as interested
in how men and women relate and the
differences between men and women as i
am in in anything going on in the world
today
so uh because ultimately
that's the stuff that determines things
see you said the ultimate issues hour
love it
here's here's just one example okay
i realized in my first year of radio
that the great divide between liberals
and conservatives and they didn't know
it that's what was so fascinating
liberals didn't know it and
conservatives didn't know it i mean some
did obviously but the great divide was
over this question
do you think people are basically good
because if you think people are
basically good then if a person rapes
murders
steels
mugs
then you blame outside forces right
society poverty racism but if you don't
believe people are basically good
then you you say well wait a minute you
are responsible not society
and that's the difference in a nutshell
you can almost trace every difference
between conservative and and liberal
views just to that question that's why
ultimate issues are so big it is and uh
you know we talk about that a lot on
this show where we go macro in a lot of
topics for example we were just talking
yesterday about how capitalism free
enterprise can only
similar to your fundamental question but
we were discussing economics a free
enterprise can only work under a system
where people are optimistic communism
can only work under pessimism and greed
i mean this idea if you're greedy in a
capitalist system
great you still don't get free stuff you
still have to do something for it right
and that question too are people
fundamentally good or bad that also goes
back to gosh i have not had enough to
drink to discuss this goes back to
spirituality and obviously kind of how
people are created and who's whose image
um
let me ask you about this because during
the election too
obviously had to discuss politics but
you talked about how and ultimately you
supported donald trump against hillary
as i think everyone did but you talked
about how it was concerning that it
seemed as though he often hadn't really
considered some of these fundamental
issues and i felt that way too for
example you know issues like abortion or
thing well how do you be 72 and and
switch your opinion within six months
well the truth here was here was my
evolution i i was adamantly opposed to
him
uh from the from the outset and i wrote
column after column a national review i
have a syndicated column in it that's
one of the places that carried it in
town hall but i said from my first
column
if he's nominated i will support him oh
wait real quick i wasn't saying you
changed your opinion i meant donald
trump changed his opinion on on life
pro-abortion to prosper i know i'm
answering you i mean yes so i i
understood that okay i didn't want you
to think i was saying you flip no i'm
i'm i'm i'm really
backing up your point
that it was clear to me or it seemed to
me he had not thought through
any of these what we call ultimate
issues right so that was you know reason
number 47 why i found him troubling okay
i didn't believe i didn't believe he was
a conservative right i mean i had a
hundred good reasons
but
no matter who the republican is it's
better than a democrat right
people don't understand the threat that
the left poses to western civilization
that's my message right
the left is a greater ultimately is a
more lethal threat to the west than than
isis is
you know i think a lot of people would
agree with you and you know something
too i remember back when perez hilton
there was the miss america scandal and
you went on cnn to debate perez not
debate but talk with perez hilton about
uh what was it carrie perjaan who who
mentioned marriage and it was a huge
thing back then and everyone watching
you on cnn with perez hilton and you
were so thoughtful and you were so
articulate and perez hilton just kind of
screeched and remember back then you
know the reaction was split among people
my age oh yeah i think perez hilton
really got the better of him but today
that's fundamentally shifted where i've
noticed millennials are actually
listening to what people have to say and
i think a big reason why you've actually
become really popular in a lot of our
circles for example extending the male
female hour
third wave feminism right that's become
such a cancer to young men that someone
who speaks honestly about you know
biological sexual differences
is almost you're almost a trailblazer
now traditionalism is almost is almost
rebellious
that's fascinating to hear i this is
this is very important for me to hear uh
what you're saying
see i have this bizarre belief
that
uh truth
uh is awesome in every generation right
you know when when i talk about male
female differences you know that just a
simple one all right men are infinitely
more visually stimulated sexually than
women are
right i mean there there are no ads
featuring men's legs oh let me think
knock jerry didn't you pull a couple of
those in sweden at one point but that
wasn't a very specific
neighborhood it was a small circulation
all right no no even that's fine even
for gays men's legs are great gay men
prove my point yes they are stimulated
looking at good-looking men as i am
looking at good-looking women right
but it's not true for lesbians and it's
not true for heterosexual women
a hundred other things stimulate them
but the visual is is not the same in any
in any shape or form anyway my point is
that it's almost like you know i i've
lived long enough to see wide ties in
fashion
narrow ties in fashion so what i do is i
keep the last one that went out of
fashion then i wait about 20 years and
they're in
and i saved a bundle of money there you
go
it's like ideas that just good ideas are
going to come back
there you go dennis prager has a rack
full of bell bottoms and skinny ties in
his closet that's right that is fat well
and that's also something that's
interesting if you even look at fashion
you know that's something i've studied
sort of as it relates to human sexuality
we had this ultra feminine era in the
70s right it made men look like women
bell bottoms narrow shoulders tight tops
and then the 80s were a rejection of it
where women looked masculine with
shoulder pads and it's just it's
something that i think a lot of people
overlooked and particularly in the era
of feminism where it went unquestioned i
mean in my lifetime feminism went
unquestioned for a good two decades
because people were terrified and now
fewer women identify as feminists than
ever and i think a big part of it is
because of people like christine hoff
summers and the work that you do have
you gotten a lot of a lot of feedback on
that from millennials or or generation z
particularly feminism do you know this
is mind-boggling we this year we'll have
350 million views wow which is is
enormous it's beyond belief to me
frankly
huge
and do you know that according to
facebook and youtube the biggest single
segment is under 35 years of age yeah
well that's us that's us too the average
viewer is a 28 year old male yep and uh
since you work with pregnant university
must be we've noticed a huge shift in
the last i'd say two years where things
that we would say at one point even
bernie sanders is a great example
pre-election anything critical of bernie
sanders like democratic socialism we
would still be excoriated online people
were furious and after the election
since bernie sanders has tipped his hand
and he's trans this and black lives
matter that and one percent this we've
seen those older videos skyrocket and
views and people like it versus dislike
with bernie sanders in the last six
months there's been a shift do you think
a big part of that is is uh president
trump sort of breaking down the ideas of
political correctness or do you just
think it's it's a symptom of culture at
large more where they're tired of it
oh i think it's both uh it doesn't work
yeah here's another isn't we do have a
few
we are on the right we do have a few
advantages one of them is
it's a secret but every poll reveals
this yeah we're happier
it's true
it is true yeah how could it not be true
if you're a black and you think
every white is out to screw you
how can you be happy
if you're a jew and you think every
non-jew is a latent anti-semite how are
you going to be happy if you're a woman
and you think every man is a misogynist
how are you going to be happy but if you
have a more realistic view of mankind
and in america in particular where in
fact the vast majority of whites only
want blacks to do well the vast majority
of men love women don't hate women the
vast majority of non-jews i can tell you
is a jew who has written a major book on
on anti-semitism
that
in all of the 4 000 years of jewish
history jews have lived the best in the
united states of america most honored
most respected least anti-semitism
but uh this stuff now about this
anti-semitism that came in with trump it
was all a lie the calls into jewish
community centers
uh you know hundreds of jewish community
centers got calls right over over there
were two guys responsible one was a
black radical and one the overwhelming
responsibility was a jewish kid in
israel a nut right yeah i know exactly a
a self-loathing nut bag would be more of
a term there that's fair well and you
also say you also do the happiness hour
i think a lot of people don't know this
you talk about how it's your moral
obligation to be happy and that to me
stuck with me
i am very touched really i am that that
that you you know i have great respect
for you that you have taken a lot of
this stuff so seriously that's my i've
written a book on happiness i do the
show every week for 18 years now every
week
but that's the biggest theme of mine
that happiness is a immoral obligation
and not just a a psychological or
emotional state
i owe it to everyone in my life my wife
my kids my parents my my colleagues at
work
the guy in the elevator next to me the
guy sitting next to me on an airplane i
owe to every one of them to have a
cheerful demeanor it is a moral
obligation and do you know that is the
toughest speech for high school kids to
hear that i give right that your
feelings
should not determine how you behave
right they have never been taught that
that and we're putting the porn lock on
your laptop that is a really rough
conversation with a 14 year old um but
how do you if some people say well first
off i think that comes from a biblical
perspective right of love that love is
an action love isn't an emotion it's how
you act toward people what do you say
when young people say well what if i'm
just having a really rough go and they
legitimately are you know they've been
dealt a bad hand and they're miserable
how do they quote unquote act you know
happy
uh
the if i said to them i have a lot of
answers one if i said to them i'll tell
you what
no matter how lousy it is if i gave you
thousand dollars a day to act cheerful
you think you could do it
of course they could it's not an issue
uh it's uh
people
people don't realize this is argument
number two they're not alone right they
think the unhappy
think that those who walk around acting
happy have life easier than they do
hello not true right all have a tough
life yeah all of us
well and you and you know what um that
was really uh a tough thing for me in
the stand-up community because there's
this idea of oh i'm this miserable uh
conflicted comic and i'm addicted to
masculine and i'm on my eighth wife and
oh but but but i'm so conflicted it's
because i'm an intellectual and i just
was like no you're just kind you're just
kind of an ass you're just at a certain
point you're just a jerk if it at some
point it's you and that's become really
popular the neurotic
narcissism and comedy and that's what it
is being perpetually unhappy is
ultimately narcissism
well going back to the unfortunately the
political if you will sure go ahead i
believe at the heart of leftism is
narcissism
how i feel is all that matters
that's what that's that's what they said
on yale to those professors that they
got rid of hey how i feel is all that
matters
so that there's no objective truth right
is israeli is yale racist give me a
break
almost the phrase sounds silly when you
say it out loud is yale racist but they
are saying yale is racist so it's it's
it's almost you can't write the parody
sometimes i mean you have
transgender lesbian feminist americans
supporting uh sharia you can't write
that kind of comedy i know that's
brilliant that is ex i i actually have
often said on my radio show i folks i
can't think of an analogy because
they've already outdone it in absurdity
right peter the people for the ethical
treatment of animals just announced that
white milk
is
is uh is white privilege right milk is
is
an aspect of white privilege i know it's
we always say the joke is it's the kind
of crazy that has freud uh rolling over
in his grave looking for a cabinet
saying i don't even know where to file
this these people are absolutely out of
their mind uh mr dennis breger again
where is the best place for people to
find you
well uh prageruniversity.com
dennisprager.com
just google me and they'll they'll have
about a year's worth of reading and
stuff and uh and of course look me up uh
i'm i'm probably on in your city on my
radio show that's true
dennis prager they can listen to me
anytime they want there's there's so
much he does everything except come out
and smash a watermelon with a mallet i
highly highly recommend reading his
books listening to his show it's been a
it's played a huge role in in shaping um
how i view the world and i know knocking
it feels the same way absolutely mr
dennis prager thank you so much we have
to have you back sir please come back
any time stephen i'll be back wait hold
on there's music what what
[Music]
ladder with crowder.com
mug club you get a seven day free trial
what do you have to lose nothing you
cheapskate
go there
try it
if even one more person subscribe to my
club to fight back against youtube
censorship
i promise
i will eat steven's dog
and you know i will
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
i do this because robots apparently love
this i don't know when that happened
with the robot but apparently robots
this is a a function that's patterned
into all i think so no robot i've ever
met has gotten the memo about that by
the way i don't know but i don't know
only the people the no robot i ever know
has done this or moonwalked either
um
galaxy explode on me
uh thank you so much to our guests i
really appreciate it you know i think
that actually having paul joseph watson
on and dennis prager created uh it it
made me think about something
interesting first off i appreciate that
paul joseph watson is consistent even if
i don't agree with him on everything
it's a rarity it's a rarity i mean he
was against what's going on in the
middle east before donald trump and he's
still against it even though you know he
runs in the same circles of people who
uh sit at the throne of lord trump um
and i think i'm split on what donald
he's done some good things he's done
some bad health care bad uh i think
his emotional sort of reactionary
approach to foreign bad i don't
necessarily know that i'm entirely
against the syria strike gerald made
some convincing arguments earlier this
week but i do think it's remarkably
inconsistent with what he said
he thought sure about syria
um but he talked about that and he
talked about how it was amazing these
people who were just cheerleaders for
donald trump no matter what and then we
spoke with with dennis prager who talked
about the ultimate issues hour
and he brought up a fundamental question
you know do you believe that people are
ultimately all good or do you believe
that people are ultimately all bad or at
least
capable of bad capable of evil that'll
shape your world view
and i think you see that with paul
joseph watts and you see that in in the
first off before the election with trump
and you certainly see it in an era
post-trump if you don't just take time
out of your day and i wasn't just just
uh kissing rear there for for dennis
prager um a big part in shaping my
worldview dennis prager thomas soul john
stossel funnily enough because because i
was a kid and i watched 20 when i was
really young 2020 and i read his
biography really really young and
learned about him being a libertarian um
these we didn't really we didn't have
fox news we didn't have am radio unless
we pirated it from plattsburgh new york
uh
and for some reason dennis prager was
one
who we were able to hear it's i don't
know exactly what it was i remember
laura ingraham early on glenn beck and i
think dennis prager and bill o'reilly
used to have a radio show but the point
is we didn't have kind of the the
talking head echo chamber that we have
here in the united states
and in some ways that's created a
different point of view i think for
myself
uh and i think even for people like like
not gay jared who wasn't really super
politically oriented before this program
um
and as dennis prager was saying my views
were shaped by having conversations at
the dinner table and every day just
sitting in and i hate to use the word
meditate because it sounds like tantric
you know yogi new age where people like
i meditate and find my center but
meditate on an idea that day or a
thought or try and figure out what do i
believe with this issue
and if you don't do that and if you
don't i mean
quite literally take time out of every
day
pick a fundamental issue pick the issue
of life
pick the issue of of
national security pick the issue of
constitutionalism pick a serious pick
the the issue of gender fluidity or you
know versus uh
masculine and feminine sort of
complementarianism pick an issue pick
five-point calvinism but every day pick
one
and just
go through just cycle it through
why do you believe what you believe
that's a credit method that we talked
about it's unbelievably useful just
continually ask questions because if you
don't ask questions in your downtime to
yourself about these issues
you're going to be asking them publicly
because you're not going to know it
doesn't mean you know everything about
every issue but it means that you need
to know
what you think about that issue
you need to know what world view you
have what values you have and if you
don't you end up with what paul joseph
watson was talking about the cult of
personality
and the danger with a cult of
personality sometimes it can be a good
person but
sometimes it can be a horrible person
and the worst case scenario sometimes it
can be a good person who turns into a
bad person because that occurs there is
nothing more corrosive to the human soul
in my experience than success
i have seen people
i've had friends i've had people who've
been on this show peop you know this
people who we've we've we've talked with
people who we've watched their star rise
become absolute monsters um i've had
friends who i knew very young growing up
uh who became
very successful actors who've since
already crashed and burned
uh and and um
that's success for a lot of people and
it's success combined with
not having taken the time to establish
what it is that they believe and i know
some people try and try and stay away
from that because oh that's ideology we
hear that all the time i'm not an idiot
log i don't believe in ideology i take
it issue to issue no you don't you don't
because if you look at it if you look at
each issue individually you will find
out that you consistently line up with
either one side of the political or
cultural spectrum more than the other
that's why most people say well i'm a
classical liberal but i feel myself
leaning more towards
the right wing now the very fact that
you feel the need to issue a caveat
means that you know you've aligned
consistently with one side and that's
because whether you want to acknowledge
it or not you have a world view everyone
does doesn't mean that you're an
ideologue who's locked in your way where
you cannot be flexible there is
flexibility intellectual flexibility is
a virtue absolutely but it is not a
virtue greater than consistency
and and being principled
and furthermore being able to argue
why you believe that you're principled
and that is one thing that uh that
dennis prager talked about really stuck
with me and it's part of my daily
routine and so i i would recommend
people going out there this week just
just try it you know whatever you do
just like you work work on your your
physical muscles work on your mental
muscle every day work on your philosophy
muscle work on that muscle work it get
the reps in uh consistently and you'll
be surprised after a week
two weeks six months uh how much more
you know and and with with how much more
clarity you see the world doesn't mean
you're not willing to change your
opinion but that means you have to have
an opinion to change as a starting off
point uh hope all as well no show monday
for mug club members easter monday we're
making it a thing plus no one here has
had a weekend
in gosh i don't know how many weeks but
we'll see you tuesday thank you so
[Music]
takes a much